have you dabbled in the CBD stuff at all
I did I am actually there's a CBD drink
that I just started oh sweet
yeah so that that was because I yeah I
do the lotion every night for my neck of
course I'm gonna have to have all of my
discs
yeah fused in disc replacements I go
through pain because I wrestle yeah
doing jujitsu guys are pulling on my
neck snapping me down front heavy get in
chokes on you know I gotta fight them
off yeah double legs hitting single legs
taking punches taking jabs right hands
uppercuts I mean head kicks too much
going on and you know like it's like you
get a boxing in the boxes checkers and
then you got MMA or being chest and you
got two games you gotta figure out
figure out who could win the game the
right way and in chess that's our game
and it's so hard because there's so many
ways to win the game but in boxing it's
for back side to side with you you made
a little difference where it was for
back side to side up down I mean you
changed angles like no other I mean I
still watch all your network stuff your
bag or thank you and there's nobody in
the world who's ever hit a bag or hit
mitts the way you hit the FRA the frosya
are ferocious punches that you do yeah I
try to mimic when I train in my boxers
my boxing trains like what are you doing
I'm like okay so I just say think it's
Mike dinner man I stay you know I'm
still trying to get it just that
mentality those that mentality going out
either kill or be killed
sure that's the way you know in
competition or in life in general
sometime it's like you know it's it's a
vicious cycle
and I just I look up to Mike a lot
because throw my whole career I've I've
always never wanted to be the person
that couldn't do it I've always wanted
to be the one to do it and exactly I
mean I remember back in 2001 at the MGM
I shouldn't Mandalay Bay Mike came
walking in and you know he came sat in
my dressing room and he was sitting down
on the floor watching me hit pads and
I'll never forget this and he looked up
he goes hey [ __ ]
you kick like a [ __ ] mules just like
so happy in my hand I was like Jesus
Mike Tyson in my [ __ ] dressing room
right now I was I mean I gotta go found
boy y'all I'm not pointing right there
like it was the coolest thing I came a
t-shirt and I said
Spanky's xxx honest at T door T's on it
and I had a flame beanie and then his
next fight when he felt fast while both
are he can walk him out with the
punishment flame beanie I said Oh Mike
that was I was one of those times in my
life where I was like man this is pretty
damn cool as a kid what not watching you
in high school and then through my
career and just always being that one
that wasn't able to make it I mean I I
don't think my life compared to yours
just you've been through some great many
great things made challenges but I kind
of compare it as we've came from nothing
and we weren't supposed to make it and
we've made it and we continue to do it
and were able to do it by show them
through our kids you know and they said
the best resemblance of a man is through
his child's and my children I'm happy
about it and make it mine you are the
same thing happy yeah it's great I just
it's just one champ talking to another
one I just like I said I'm still
competing I still love it I still have
the hunger I still have the grind and I
remember Mike said not to quote exactly
but he's talking about walking to the
cage and people saying how do you feel
when you walk into the cage and he said
I'm in such fear of losing for my fans
losing for my family but by the time I
walk into the cage I'm unstoppable I
walk into the ring I'm unstoppable
and every time I'm I fight every time I
walk out every single time I get ready
for my fight I had that same mentality
I'll be walking out I have tears coming
down my eyes because it's I have the
fear is leaving my body so once I do
step into the cage yeah I feel
invincible amazing and there's no
feeling in the world like it and I think
Mike's the only look at feeling like
that other fighters can feel it feel
like that cuz it's most loneliest
feeling in the world to be a fighter
yeah cuz it's do only you you out get it
up and train you got to get up and run
you got to get up and do weight training
you got to get up and spar you got to
get up and wrestle you had to go through
all these things and then you go get in
the ring by yourself and no one else to
help you know I got a survival yeah and
then it's a it's a vicious vicious
competition but you know at the other
day I got to make sure I prepare for it
and I say I mean that's my little story
about my amazing no thank you for
sharing that
[Music]